[Musique]
tout part du constat que les yvelinois
vont généralement à paris pour écouter
de la musique classique
mathieu arnaud décide alors de produire
de la musique localement il fonde alors
qu'istres de paris et saint germain en
laye l'ensemble des entremonts de
l'orchestré symphonique tous les
instruments à cordes violon alto
violoncelle contrebasse tous les
instruments à vent notre première série
néanmoins sera donc plus petit orchestre
pour développer progressivement celui ci
mathilde de blondel vie depuis ses 4 ans
une histoire d'amour avec son
violoncelle
en décembre elle décide de rejoindre
l'orchestré symphonique est très
agréable de pouvoir se projeter aussi
sur un peu plus sur la longueur sur ce
genre de chose quand on vous appelle
juste pour une série c'est vrai qu'il ya
une date ca prends pas trop de choses
laissent aussi créer d'autres relations
avec les musiciens avec l'ensemble des
acteurs
la musique aussi et c'est vrai que ce
qui est très agréable dans cet ensemble
ce que il ya vraiment une solution
socialement emballé par le projet le
chef d'orchestre félix mathus et chaises
a de suite accepté de rejoindre le
groupe
les thèmes de la joie et de l'humour
seront principalement abordé au
programme est prévu la plaisanterie
musicale de mozart la symphonie numéro
45 de haydn ou encore le célèbre
beethoven de tout acte et il n'y a pas
des traditions ya pas d d'habitude donc
ce qui m'intéressait surtout c'est ça et
les sérieux du projet un projet bien
bâti c'est très important et je le
constate chaque fois que tout est
correspond un grand sérieux une grande
solidité une belle
vision d'avenir au total une dizaine de
représentations sont prévues en 2020 le
29 mars prochain l'orchestré viennois se
produira dans l'église de saint germain
en laye à 15 heures